[Music]
hold on Hallmark hey Jonathan no I'm on
the set of ET Canada yeah we're
promoting the holiday Center hey can you
get Lohan thanks cool cool I would do
another movie with Lindsay Lohan
tomorrow like she's so talented thank
you there's not a day that I would not
want to be on set with Lindsay shooting
a movie especially with Lacey like put
us all together maybe we do the Jingle
Bell Rock I don't know like hey if they
ride it I'll do it the right time to
rock the night away but I think it would
be important to see like me and Lindsay
play something different
because we've watched Us Fall in Love
already so maybe we'd be best friends or
you know brother and sister and have
like some fun Christmas hijinks happen I
mean I'm here for it kind of seems like
you get it but until that reunion
happens Jonathan's all about the holiday
sitter wait
are you asking me to babysit when we set
out to make the holiday sitter it was
really important to me that we didn't do
a coming out story and that we didn't
make a movie that was specifically for a
queer audience or for lgbtq plus people
we set out to make a movie for everybody
one two three huh